it's been a rough few years a pandemic
snap recession now an inflation crisis
in times like this we need somebody
looking out for us putting our interests
first
batman isn't around so who can we turn
to
well it's certainly not washington d.c
comedian dennis miller once said that
washington d.c is to lying what
wisconsin is to cheese
and he's not wrong
and the main thing washington lies about
is money
they'll beg borrow or steal to help
themselves using any inside information
they can
while you're a day late and a dollar
short
and the war in ukraine is no different
vladimir putin was building up troops
along the ukraine border for months
washington knew it biden knew it there
were briefings
the satellite images got passed around
congress the sanctions talk was swirling
i've made it absolutely clear
to president putin it's the last thing
i'll say
that
if he moves on ukraine
the economic consequences for his
economy are going to be devastating
devastating
this invasion was brewing for months and
washington was assembling the economic
sanctions packages behind closed doors
they knew this would impact the global
economy and you directly
so you would figure that congress
elected to represent our interests would
do something ahead of time to warn us
and protect us against what was coming
guard americans from the economic
turmoil
maybe they'd take early action to
cushion us from economic warfare get
ahead of the energy crisis brace us for
the commodity spikes and warn us about
the supply chain fallout
sounds reasonable right
well
it's not how dc works
instead it looks like congress saw this
as a gold rush
they knew what sanctions could be coming
down
and all they had
dollar signs in their eyes
members from both sides of the political
aisle poured money into the market
buying up defense stocks energy stocks
so as ukraine burned to the ground
congress got rich
it starts with debbie wasserman schultz
the former chair of the democrat party
in late january more than a month before
the invasion
wasserman schultz purchased up to 45 000
worth of patterson uti energy stock
what do they do
the company drills for oil and gas drill
debbie drill
and it's
shot through the roof since then jumping
nearly 60 percent in value since she
bought it
she sits on the energy and national
security subcommittees too
is buying up energy stocks
while national security situation here
is looming
she didn't buy any windmill stock
that's so weird
funny
because biden was predicting energy
prices were going down at the time
maybe she knew something we didn't
and unfortunately she's not alone
then we have lois frankel
another democrat sitting on the energy
subcommittee
she snatched up two energy stocks in
early january
hess
and diamondback energy
which if both jumped nearly 10 cents
it's so funny because frankel's a member
of the progressive caucus which backs
the green new deal
and she's buying fossil fuel companies
in the run-up to a war
this is what we're dealing with
but it's not just in the house the
senate is getting in on the war
profiteering trades too
tommy tuberville who sits on the armed
services committee
which you figure might know a thing or
two about potential war sanctions
snagged up to 15 000 worth of chevron
and another 50 grand worth of duke
energy
over a month before the invasion
looks like tommy was pretty clued in
that russia was going in
or maybe
tommy was just reading the tea leaves
and it's not just energy
senator thomas carper of delaware
he brought up shares in the world's
largest producer of fertilizer materials
and russia and belarus happened to be
the two largest exporters of fertilizer
and it just so happens that carper is
already up 40
on the january investment
we've been going after congress for the
appearance of insider trading since the
start of the show you know we targeted
pelosi and you know her perfect timing
that golden touch she has
and this situation is no different
it doesn't matter what party you belong
to the role of the people's house is to
protect us
not members of congress
we reached out to each member's office
for comment
and one got back to us
senator carper's office telling us his
investments are handled by independent
financial advisors
independent
wow
so maybe the senator's financial advisor
knew there was going to be a war in
ukraine too
smart guy
but it's a sad reality
what's happening in our nation's capital
and there's a lot more where this all
came from and we're going to be
reporting
on this suspicious congressional stock
trading in the run-up to the ukraine war
next week too so ride with prime time
congress wasn't warning us about high
gas prices and fertilizer and food
shortages in january
what was congress doing in january
oh yeah
they were morning january 6th
and then the rest of the january they
just scolded us to wear a mask
but behind the scenes they were plotting
the prophet of war
time and time again members of congress
chose to put themselves ahead of the
american people
even after you ready raking in a record
amount of tax revenue
according to reports the federal
government collected over 1.8 trillion
dollars
in total taxes
through the first five months of fiscal
year 2022. new record
so where did it go
congress is just wasting it on pork
fraud and abuse
they're spending money to defend another
nation's borders not ours
keep other nations streets safe not ours
and helping other countries produce more
energy not ours
you would think that at least they'd
give us back some of the cash
but there's no tax cut coming anytime
soon there's no inflation relief there's
no gas tax holiday
instead they're trying to spend billions
more
just paying back their political donors
and just driving up inflation higher and
higher
your money
down the drain
while they call their financial advisor
and make it rain
now it's the people of ukraine who were
being taken advantage of
the world sees suffering but congress
they see dollar signs hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else